This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor
Hello everyone and welcome to Daily with
Doc and Becca. My name is Ruth Ellen
Sanchez and I am going to be your host
today. Filling in for Rebecca Dukes. Hey
Becca, we love you. Um this program is
sponsored for by dailywithdoc.com
and if somebody referred you to this
program please get back with that
person. Also
this program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not meant to treat,
diagnose or cure any or prevent any
diseases nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as testimonials by the
individual experiences of the
individual. Results may vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
about income or health. And as an
empowered individual, you do have
options. So today we have an amazing
woman, my mentor.
I love this woman so much. She has no
idea. I just adore her. Um she is a
powerful motivational speaker. She
creates inspiration and love
everywhere that she goes. She's just
amazing.
And I am just so grateful that I can
call her friend and call her my mentor
and I just love her. I got to find her.
There she is. And I'm going to go ahead
and bring Miss Mrs. Cheryl Moley on the
with us if I could. There she goes.
Hello.
>> Hi. How are you? Thank you so much. I'm
so excited to be here.
>> I'm very excited for you to be here.
It's it's an honor to be here with you.
Oh, thank you so much.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. I'm excited.
>> I'm excited, too. So, today we have a
great topic.
>> Yes.
>> And um which is escaping me at the
moment. Uh finding purpose and
confidence and helping others.
>> Yeah. That is important.
>> Yes. And you do that.
>> Yeah. You know what? I love it. I I've
done it for a long time, Ruth. I feel
like it's been forever, but you know
what a blessing it's been in my life,
right? And I think all of us are are
here because
um because we do need to help each other
and because that I believe is where we
find true happiness. And you know, I I
have a lot of friends that are very well
off and and that's wonderful. Um I have
no problem with uh making money, with
helping people make money. Um, but you
know, I I've found that over the years
that a lot of people even with a lot of
money and a lot of things, they're still
not happy. And so I've just been so
grateful and blessed, you know, to be
able to do what I do and helping others
because I think that's where, you know,
like I said, true happiness is found.
>> I agree with you 100%.
>> Yeah. because I know I feel better when
I'm helping somebody and they're,
you know, their life is changing and
getting better or they're able to just
look at things in a different way, which
is, you know, really amazing.
>> Yeah. And I think I think that everybody
at some point in their life is looking
for a way to help other people or they
realize that, hey, you know what? I've
really got to get out there and do
something and help others. And I don't
think there's a better feeling than when
we do that.
So, I love that and and I think it's
just so important and to have, you know,
this vehicle um that we do have um you
know, being able to help others get
healthy. I mean, I've seen, you know,
and again, I feel like I've been doing
this forever, but I've seen, especially
since the pandemic,
um, that people are just getting more
and more interested in in really in
really getting healthy. But the problem,
right, that we see out there is that
there's so much confusion. There's so
much I'm not sure what I should do and
everyone's telling us this and
everyone's telling us that and you
should do this and today this is good
and tomorrow it isn't and tomorrow you
should try this and today you should do
this and I mean it just gets so
confusing and I really think that
there's a lot of people out there who
want to feel better, who want to get
healthy, let's say, and they just are so
confused that they're kind frozen in
place and that they just they don't know
where to turn. They don't know, you
know, where to even start. Is that what
you're seeing out there?
>> It is. Yeah. People are very confused
and there is a lot of misinformation out
there and it's
it's hard to even know where to find the
actual truth.
You know, when you're looking things up
and everything and you know we make a
joke of Dr. Google, which
a lot of people use Dr. Google, but we
all have to remember who is in charge of
the information that gets on there. So
then where do you go?
>> Yeah.
>> To get it, the honest truth, you know?
>> Yeah. I think that's so true. And and
how do we even know like what the truth
is,
>> right? I mean, and that's what you're
saying. You're saying that there's so
much that's put out there. And you know,
as we know, Ruth,
things like that has everything to do
with money. And people are saying things
that aren't necessarily true, that are
misleading, that are guiding people in
the wrong direction because of the
importance
um of money, right? And so it's just so
it is it's hard for all of us to to
understand and to see that. And and the
thing that the thing that I love is in
the 30 years that I've been doing this,
nothing's changed.
Dr. Wallik hasn't changed. He's said the
exact same thing for the last 30 years.
And that's 30 years that I've known him.
He was doing it way before me. But um
but he's never which I which I love this
so much, right? He's never changed his
message. He is 1,00%
consistent in what he says, in what he
does, and in his mission to to help us
and to help um the general population
um really take control of their own
health and and feel better along the
way.
>> Yeah, that's very true. And now people
are saying what he said the whole time
and acting like it's new information.
>> Yeah.
>> Crazy.
>> That's absolutely right. And and acting
like, oh, it's just the first we're
hearing about it. And it's like, yeah,
it's it's been that his his information
has been out there for
years and years and years. And again,
you know, a lot of times it's easy to
change what you're saying depending on
the fad or depending on what other
people are saying or depending on this
and depending on that. And that's what I
love about Dr. Wallock. It's never
changed. It's always been the same.
We've always said the same thing. Our
mission has always been the same. And I
love that because of course, yes, the
consistency is wonderful. But I think
even more than that, it gives all of us
um I don't know, we always say you can
take that to the bank, right? But um you
know, you can really you can really have
I I mean it's bringing hope to thousands
and thousands of people. And that's why
I think it's so important for each of us
um you know really to take up take it
upon ourselves to yes get ourselves
healthy and I love that and I I really
believe that and I think it's super
super important um but to even take it
one step more and help other people and
get that information out right and it's
this and and I always think about this
and we've got some awesome people on
this call today and I'm sure a lot of
others listening and The thing is is
that I can't reach all of the people,
Ruth Ellen, that you can reach. You
can't reach the people I can reach or
Marilyn or Mary or Sher or Albert or AJ,
all of us can reach different people.
And that's what I think is so important
and and to remember that every single
person, no matter who you are, no matter
where you are, you can make a
difference. Yes. In your life,
absolutely, which is absolutely where it
starts. But then so important to
remember that you can make a difference
in the people's lives around you that in
fact we couldn't reach. Right? So I love
that idea of
you know because well and and the reason
why I even say this is years ago um I
was trying to figure out after I had my
kids I have kids that are on my land 18
twins 18-year-old twins.
They're amazing and I can't even believe
that.
>> They are amazing and they're beautiful.
Both of them.
>> Oh my gosh. Absolutely stunning.
>> Thank you. Thank you. They they've been,
you know, it's like the most rewarding
and at the same time, as I know, you
know, hard experience in my life, right?
But but just the joy of um you know
raising kids that are really I mean I
have always been like
the most important thing really I
believe this is to be kind right just to
be a good human and I love the whole
idea and look let's be honest we're all
going to think different things we're
going to have different opinions we some
of us are on the right some of us are on
the left some of us are on the left some
of are on the right. It doesn't matter.
That doesn't matter. What matters is
that we're all human beings and to treat
each other accordingly
is really
is really what it's all about. Like I'm
the same person I was
20 years ago. Sure, I've had more
experiences and so so are a lot of my
friends. and we think different things
and we come at things different ways
because of our past, because of the way
we've been raised, because of all of
these different things. That doesn't
matter though, right? What matters is
being kind and being um generous and
being grateful and helping people
because again, it's not for them
necessarily. It's what makes us happy.
>> That's true.
>> Yeah,
>> it's very true. So, listen, I could go
on and on and on about that, Ruth.
But, um, but yeah, it's just it's been
great. It really has.
>> Yeah. And usually when I sign off,
sometimes I forget. I always say, "Be
kind.
Just be kind."
>> Yeah.
>> Because you don't know what somebody is
going through
>> at all. And we can all put on that brave
face to be in front of people or around
people, you know, it kind of the thing,
you know, with the girl the of course
we're not recommending any kind of
anti-depressants, but you know, they put
up the mask, you know, the fake smiley
face and um you just don't know what
people are going through at all.
>> No, you don't. You like none of us have
any idea. And guess what, Ruth Ellen?
Everybody's going through something,
right?
>> That's true.
>> No matter what.
>> Very true.
>> Yeah.
>> So, and I love the whole idea, and I
really believe this, that
what you put out there, kindness,
patience, whatever it is, which patience
has always been kind of hard for me, but
I got I'm I'm good at kindness, but no.
Um, but that's what will come back to
you, right? That's what will come back
to you. Like think about it. Like just
smile at someone as you're out and
about, right? Just smile. It doesn't
take much to have a smile on your face,
>> right? And the difference between that,
I mean, if you really look around, I'm
not seeing too many smiles these days.
I'm really not. Right. And I'm not
seeing
>> um people reach out to help other
people.
Even just in a helping someone with
their luggage or whatever. I've been
traveling. So, that's why I kind of
brought that up because I was really
noticing that. And
>> the difference when somebody offers to
help,
>> it makes a world of difference for you
and for them. So,
it's important.
>> Yeah. Even just saying good morning or
good afternoon and how's your day?
>> Right.
>> You know,
>> absolutely. I think that's so true. And
and a lot of times like I'll be
thinking, "Oh, I wonder if that person
like if you're sitting by someone in an
airplane, I wonder if that person wants
me to talk to them or you know what
exactly, right? Should I give them their
space or whatever else?" But just like
you're saying good morning or good
afternoon or whatever, hi or you know,
>> nice to see you, whatever. Just making
that connection, I think, is super
important.
>> I agree with you. And it's important to
say hi and hello to the cashier at the
grocery store who's got a line a mile
long and she's stressed and you can
just bring a little brightness, you
know, and sometimes they'll look at you
and they'll smile, but they'll keep
going, you know, and then it just
especially um
sometimes I've been a few places in uh
like we were at um oh magic
great adventure. It was great adventure
in in New Jersey.
>> Yep.
>> And this lady was like yelling at the
person in the information booth, you
know, and um so I walked up and I we had
to wait a few minutes, but when I came
back um I was talking to the girl and I
was like being nice and I was being kind
and she was thanking me for being nice
and kind. I said, "Well, my voice speaks
for a thousand people. You do an amazing
job." And the next time somebody yells
at you, please remember this moment. And
she started crying. And then I started
crying. I'm like, "It's okay." And she's
like, "I'm never going to forget that."
>> And that that made me feel like a
million dollars.
>> Just helping her or sharing with her
that she's amazing because everybody is
amazing in all of their ways. the
different ways. You know, we all have
like that cranky bear that might come up
and maybe not amazing in that moment,
but there's no reason to be mean to
people that are doing service for you.
>> Yeah. No, I love I I love what you're
saying and it just kind of reminded me
of um I just listened to this fantastic
TED talk um and I can try and find it
and and send it to you guys because it
is it is really good. But, you know, it
talks about like you said and we've been
talking about the importance of being
kind to others and and and the
importance of knowing that everyone's
going through something and and just to
really always remember that. And I think
even one step more that I've really been
focusing on and concentrating in like
the last little bit here like maybe in
the last year is really how
you're talking to yourself,
right? Are you treating yourself like
you would treat your best friend?
And I'm pretty sure that unless we're
conscientiously doing that,
then I think that we're not right and
we're a lot harder on ourselves. And men
absolutely I think are, but I think
women even more um from what I've seen
and from my experience is just that
we're so hard on ourselves. We're so
ready and willing to give somebody else,
our friends, right? We're really um
willing to give them a um you know,
great job. You're doing so good. And we
can pick out like the greatest things
about our friends, but can we do that
for ourselves, right? Can we really pick
out the things that we're great at and
appreciate those things and be grateful
for those things?
>> Yeah, it's a little harder to do to
yourself.
>> It really is. It really is harder. And
and let me tell you, um I grew up
without a lot of confidence at all. Like
I really
did not have
confidence in myself, right? In myself.
I I really I really didn't. And I for
years and years and years, I really
wished that I was someone else. I I
always wished that I was um one of my
other friends, right? Or somebody else.
Like I wanted to be the head
cheerleader. Oh, listen. I was never a
cheerleader. Um, I wanted to be in the
drill team. I didn't make the drill
team. Um, right. So, there was always
something that I wanted to do that I I
didn't make it. Like I I literally
thought I failed at everything. Like
that's the way that I grew up, right?
And so it was always super important to
me um to make sure that my kids had
self-confidence,
right? And that I like my daughter was
asking me the other day, this is
fascinating to me. So she goes, "I can't
believe that you never had
self-confidence, right? Because I have
plenty of it now."
And I think that's because I was blessed
enough at a young age, well younger than
I am now, but I was like 27 years old to
really find my purpose in life, right?
And I think that's so important because
if we can find our purpose in life, I
think that's what gives us confidence.
And I I uh had like so much um gratitude
for Dr. Wallick because our big thing
was he would say, "Don't worry, Cheryl.
I'm going to believe in you until you
can believe in yourself." And I was
like, "Oh, okay. Well, that's going to
be great because um I don't believe in
myself. I was really, you know, I wasn't
even sure what I was doing or how I was
going to do it, but he was there." And
that's always been um something that I
love to talk about that I want to be
that same person for other women,
right? Because I want to believe in them
until they can believe in themselves,
right? And I think all of us can do
that. And and I think when we find our
passion in life or our purpose in life,
I think that alone gives us that
confidence.
And I feel incredibly blessed that most
of both of my kids have
really a lot of self-confidence,
which makes it a little harder to be
their mom sometimes, but but it's the
best. And they really they really do,
you know, have that confidence and have
been um able to like really decide at a
much younger age than I was um what they
really want to do, what their passions
are, what they you know how. And I
always say I say, you know what you and
I've always said this, you can do and be
whoever you want to be. And I just want
you to really think about and consider
how you're going to be helping people,
right? how whatever your purpose is,
>> it's up to you, right? I'm here to
support you 100%. I love you 100%, but
it's up to you.
>> But I want you to think about in
whatever you decide you're going to do,
how you're going to be helping other
people, how you're going to be enriching
their lives, how you can help them, how
you can be of service to them. Because
if you can have that as your mindset,
then that is what will bring the
happiness into your life. Sorry, I
talked a lot. Um,
>> no, that's perfect.
>> It's perfect. Don't be sorry. That was
phenomenal.
>> But yeah, I just think that that's that
that's
where confidence comes from. Mhm.
>> Oh, let me say one more thing about
confidence because and I've done a ton
of research about this whole confidence
thing because I couldn't figure out why
I never had any. And I couldn't
necessarily figure out how like I felt
like one day I just woke up and I was
full of confidence. That's not true.
That is not that is not how it happened.
That's how I like kind of remember it,
but that is not how it happened. And I
always used to believe that if you're a
leader, you're born a leader. If you're
not born a leader, then you're not a
leader. And too bad, you're going to be
a follower. That's really what I always
believed, right?
>> And so
I learned like a little while ago, few
years ago, that that just isn't the
case, right? That there's this thing
called personal growth. And the
interesting thing is is as I was working
with Dr. Wallik 30 years ago and
traveling all over the countryside with
him and the world actually.
>> Um my confidence was growing a little
bit at a time, right? Growing and
growing and I didn't necessarily know
that, oh this is personal growth and we
need to do personal growth. I don't
think it was as big a thing. I know it
wasn't as big a thing in my life um as
it is now and the importance of that,
but I think that
that that's what was happening over a
period of time. And Dr. Wallick wouldn't
let me like get out of things that I
didn't want to do. Like, you know, uh
you need to stand up. first of all, you
need to um talk about these products and
be able to tell people about these
products. And I was like, listen, I've
already tried to sell some things in my
life and that did not go over well. So,
I mean, I tried to sell Cutco and thank
goodness my grandma bought something
because if not, then I would have never
sold a thing. Um, but vacuums, I tried
to sell vacuums. So I tried to sell
different things and I think I was
missing the whole point of that only the
only reason I say that is because
I didn't realize that it's just about
telling a story and loving
really loving
what you are wanting to share with other
people.
So that's kind of what I what I learned.
And I also kind of thought that
like confidence just happens to you,
right? It just happens. I don't think
that that's necessarily it. I think it I
think you have to get out there and put
yourself out there and do some things
you don't want to do and fall down and
then make that decision that hey, no
matter what,
if I fall down, I'm going to get back up
and I'm going to keep moving forward and
I'm going to learn from whatever it is
that happened.
And that's how I really believe that
confidence is built.
I agree with you 100%.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it's, you know, overcoming your
fear and doing it anyway. Yeah.
I mean, three years ago, I would have
never pictured myself doing what I'm
doing right now, knowing how to do what
I do. You know, I would have never ever
thought I would be hosting a podcast
or doing anything. half the stuff that
I've done in my life, you know, I just
it's it was just pushing through the
fear, falling down, getting up, figuring
out what you did wrong, and fixing it
and keep going. And sometimes it takes
three or four times before you figure
out how to tweak something,
you know. I
>> Yeah, I totally get it. And I It is very
accurate what you just said.
very accurate because it doesn't just
happen. You know,
>> you you I mean, when we're babies and
we're learning how to walk, we fall down
a lot. And our parents don't say, "You
stupid idiot. Why'd you trip?" They say,
"Oh,
get back up. Come on. Come on here." You
know, and we have that kind of
encouragement, you know, but later we
have to be our own cheering station,
you know.
And uh I mean I can think of so many
times in my life that it was like not
easy to just keep going, you know, and
you just learn and um
you have Yeah, I I love Dr. Wallik. I
love the products. They changed my life.
And more importantly, besides that, cuz
those things are important,
I love how I feel
>> while I'm doing what I do. Taking the
supplements changed my life. I mean, I
was like 220
pounds
before when I first started Youngevity.
I had vertigo so bad I couldn't even I
couldn't drive anymore. I was a limo
driver. I couldn't bend my one leg
because it was messed up from you know
uh bumper-to-bumper traffic 300 miles a
day sometimes and um I started taking
what was recommended and then the
vertigo went away and then my muscles
and my body started to get better and I
lost weight and then you know little by
little I've gained confidence in myself
and everything else because I wasn't
putting myself down anymore being
the 235 lbs that I was before that, the
220 lbs. Oh, I can't drive. No, it's not
my ear. Cuz my one boss kept saying,
"It's your ear. It's your ear." I'm
like, "No, it's my neck." I fell and I
jarred my neck. It's my neck. and um
you know and then helping people and
meeting people and going to the events
and meeting people like you, getting
invited to your house on my birthday,
having a Christmas party and like
different things, you know, I've just
I've grown. I am not the same person I
was at all in 201 um 15 when I started.
I'm not. I've grown. Parts of me are the
same, but I've grown a lot.
>> Yeah.
>> Stumbling and falling and picking myself
back up. Just like you said.
>> Yeah. But isn't that like to me it's
almost freeing.
>> Right. It's freeing. It's like, oh my
gosh,
if I don't have to be perfect, if I
don't have to worry about
um always being on, I'm hardly ever on.
I look, I'm just like unapologetically
me. I like really seriously. I'm just
like listen, this is it. And and I don't
want to pretend to be something else or
someone else, right? because it feels to
me like it took me forever
to get to this point, right? And and I
still I still kind of
have to remind myself, right? I have to
remind myself. I have to say, "Oh,
yeah."
You know, um
think about the things that you've done
and don't worry. Like I love this whole
idea of just the past is the past.
That's all. You can't you don't want to
bring the past into
the present and you certainly don't want
to take it with you into the future,
right? And so I think that that's
something that we all have to
I guess work on and and just remember
and not beat ourselves up, right? Not
beat ourselves up. No, we cannot beat
ourselves up.
>> No,
>> we can take the lesson with us and work
on being better.
>> Yes.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> And the And I think the joy is in the
present like right here. And and I love
that saying. Um I've heard it a couple
of times. Um now let me think if I can
remember it. So depression is thinking
about
when you think about the past, that's
depression. And when you have anxiety,
that's worrying about the future,
right? Because you're so worried about
what's going to happen and and and all
of this. So, if you can just stay in the
present as much as possible, I really
think that that's where I think that's
where we find joy and and the ability to
grow.
>> Yeah. Being right here, right now in
this moment.
>> Yeah. Okay. Now, I have a question for
you, Ruth Ellen. Can Mary has her hand
up now. Can we take questions?
>> Oh, absolutely. Absolutely.
>> All right. Let me bring Mary on and Mary
should be able to unmute.
>> Yes.
>> Hi.
>> How you doing?
>> Good.
>> Good. I know you could talk all day, I'm
sure.
>> Oh, listen. I don't know.
>> But um uh two things. I wanted to bring
in a question from Barbara. Actually,
she asked a question in the chat and her
question is, "How do you help someone
who has low self-esteem
um have more confidence?"
>> Yeah,
>> that's from Barbara in the chat.
>> Yeah, that's a really really good
question and I feel like
I've been working on that myself
and and I've helped a lot of women.
Look, the whole thing is I think
that the way I would help them is where
like what are they doing in their life
um that they
what are they what are some things
they're doing that can create that
confidence.
So, if you're not doing anything that's
hard, if you're not doing anything, if
you're not consciously like, you know
what, I'd like to build my
self-confidence.
If you're not thinking that, and if
someone has low confidence and they're
they have to start thinking like, you
know what, I really want to build my
confidence. I really want to have and
and maybe it's confidence in something,
>> right? So, for me it was um confidence
in speaking because let me tell you, I
really didn't like that. And I'll never
forget the first time I ever got up and
spoke. It was years ago. But um I had a
friend and he's like, "You're going to
get up and and speak." I'm like, "Oh,
no, I'm not." And there were all these
people in the room and he's like, "Nope,
you got to get up and speak." And I'm
like, "Oh, no." And he's like, "You're
going to do it no matter what." There's
the slides. And you know what? The only
thing I can remember is the person that
walked out while I was speaking.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Cuz I was mortified. I was like, well,
what wasn't I saying that they had to
get up and leave? Okay, Cheryl, it
doesn't even have anything to do with
you. Okay, but the whole point is is
you've got to find something that you're
that's kind of hard, right? That's hard
and then master that. So that's one
thing that I would that's one thing that
I would have them do like what's
something that's hard for you,
>> right? Is it hard to work out? Is it
hard to you know what's it been what's
it been in your life? And this is where
the health coaching stuff comes in I
think is just helping people along these
lines and being able because I think
you'll build confidence in yourself if
you do what you say you'll do. Mh.
>> So, you're like, "You know what? It's
been very hard for me to go to the gym.
I'm going to have to go to the gym." And
then you get up and whether you want to
or not, listen, I already get it. I
don't always want to at all, right? Or I
don't always want to do this or that or
whatever it is,
>> right? But you do it anyway because you
said you would,
>> right? And so, it's like keeping your
word to yourself. I think that's one
thing I would do and just kind of talk
with that person and be like,
>> you know, again, what's been hard for
you? What have you what do you feel like
you're failing at? Let's say, right?
Because we all have those feelings like,
oh my gosh, I could be better at this or
I could do better at that or whatever it
is. And so maybe just talking about what
that is and then setting that goal to to
do that hard thing to build that
confidence.
>> Okay,
>> so that's one thing. And then one other
thing I would do and I think this is
really important for all of us is
uh mantras right so getting because you
have to change the way your brain thinks
about you about yourself because if you
don't have confidence then that's
because you believe that either you
can't do something that you said you
would do or you're struggling or you're
looking out saying well My goodness,
everybody's good at this and that and
the other and I just suck. Well, you got
to find something. Everyone's good at
something, right? All of us are uniquely
different,
>> right?
>> And so, we all have something to offer.
We all have something that we can work
on to become better at. But having that
mantra is super important. And another
thing too along with these mantras is
that I've been doing that's made a big
difference in my life is
really
having uh I I always call it a come to
Jesus meeting with myself and
telling myself every day that I love you
>> because let me tell you that's not easy.
The first time I said it, I was like, I
couldn't even say I couldn't even say
it. And how weird is that? Because we
have if we can't love ourselves, how on
earth are we going to love anyone else,
right? And so, and by loving yourself, I
do think that that will help with the
confidence and and saying a mantra,
right? a mantra that you love that will
stop you from treating yourself poorly
because that's not going to work. And
and whatever you know, whatever mantra
you want to I have tons of different
mantras that I say
um and and one of my mantras that I
absolutely love is I can do all things
through Christ who strengthens me.
That's one of my mantras and I love that
mantra because it stops the negative
thinking
>> when I start thinking, "Oh, I don't
think I can do that. Oh, I probably
can't do that. Oh, I don't," you know,
no, let's stop right there. So, just a
mantra. And you guys, there's tons of
different mantras um that you can
certainly um just go like on either
YouTube, they have them on there, or
any, you know, anywhere. And really even
in um the health community, the um our
new community that we have um we have um
some things in there too that you can
use as mantras. And I'll be adding way
more things because I've been gone a
little bit, but I've I'll be adding way
more things um in there as far as the
great mantras that I love that I use.
>> So those two things.
>> Okay. And and just building on the
mantras piece, it sounds like having
them written written down. Yes.
>> In addition to so you can remember to
say them at first at least is sounds
pretty critical.
>> Oh well that's why I'm not just winging
one off for you right now because I'd
have to go in here and look for it. But
that's because and I do I say them every
single day. But I don't necessarily
memorize anything. Like I don't know why
I have like a I should pro that's what I
should probably do. Build my confidence
in memorizing because I am not good at
that. I can tell you. But it's just
because I don't make myself do it. I
just don't do it. So but yeah, write
them down. Write down the mantras and
then say them every single morning and
every single night right before you go
to sleep. That's I think the best way to
do it.
>> Perfect. And one one other question, the
second question, Ruth Ellen
>> is um
>> it sounds like uh you I guess the
question is what is the importance in
your mind of having a coach? It sounds
like in the beginning,
>> you know, your coach may have been Dr.
Wallik and he pushed you. Yep.
>> So someone that's going to, you know,
maybe sees more in you than you do
yourself. And uh what's your your your
thought on having a coach of some sort,
a parent maybe or a coach friend that
can help you find your purpose and
confidence in helping others and
yourself.
>> What's the importance of that?
>> Look,
to me, there's nothing more important
than that. Not one thing is more
important than having a coach. And I
don't only believe this when it comes to
having a business or being a health
coach or being in a community. I think
that in every part of life
>> because look, I think that most people
feel alone
>> in some way. Now, they may have a
fantastic home life and everything's
great and wonderful and they've got a
great family, but when it comes to, you
know, they have this desire to build a
business to help people and but they
feel alone in that because they don't
have a coach, because they don't have
somebody that can Look, I love this
whole accountability thing. It about
drives me crazy because
I I don't love to be held accountable,
right? I But I need that. That's exactly
why I need it, right? That's why all of
us need it. But I don't think that's the
most important thing about a coach.
>> I think the most important thing about a
coach is somebody there
who is going to lift you up when it gets
when it gets hard because of course
it'll get hard. Life's freaking hard,
right? I mean, life's not easy. It's not
meant to be easy, by the way, which I
always thought that it was.
And I'll never forget, my mom used to
always tell us, well, I'm going to make
that farm life so hard that when you get
out in the real world, it's going to be
easy. So, let me tell you, that's
exactly what happened. And I'm super
blessed because of that because nothing
seems as hard as that did. So, I'm like,
well, as long as I'm not on the farm,
I'm good. Um, you know, but I really do
believe that a coach I think that's the
difference between being successful and
not and not being successful. And maybe
you can be successful because I went a
long time without a coach. Mhm.
>> Um, and so then if you don't have a
coach, then you've got to do it on your
own and you've got to
figure out how you're going to do that.
>> Now, the problem with that is that I
found is I could do it, but I didn't
know how to tell somebody else how to do
what I did. I'm like, "Oh, just go out
and do it." Well, yeah. Well, what?
Right. So, and that's when having a
coach, yes, is important. And also
having a system is super important.
>> But I still believe you can have a
system and if you don't have a coach, if
you don't have like a, you know, like a
person like your person
>> that's there to help you and support
you. And that's why a lot of times I
think that Paul and I try to do our best
that if somebody doesn't have a coach or
if if somebody doesn't have somebody
that they can rely on that helps them
then we try to be that person. But it's
not going to ever be as good as you know
like as your I always call it your
wingman right because that's really what
it is. But it's somebody who can and
again it's not necessarily
it you can hold each other accountable.
Yes, but I think it's more it's way more
than that in giving that person the
support and hope that they need when the
going gets tough and you know you kind
of uh work off each other and you know
not somebody will be down one day and up
the next and then you can kind of you
know you can kind of help each other
out. But I think it's essential. I I
really I really think it's essential and
if you look at anybody who owns a either
a big business or who owns a business
and that they have people that they
surround themselves with um that do just
that and they kind of all do different
things but I think that the one- on-one
um coach is super important and everyone
that I know that's you know has a coach
like no no no matter like I'm talking
about, you know, like even Tony Robbins
as a coach, right? That's what I'm
saying.
>> Yeah. So,
>> athletes and the like. So,
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. That's right. And the
the athlete Well, and that's a perfect
point, right?
>> The better the athlete, I think, the the
greater the coach, too.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right.
>> And being able to do what that coach
tells you to do.
>> That's kind of hard for me sometimes
because you guys know Paul's my coach.
Yeah,
>> I'm like, "No,
I drive him crazy." But there's nothing
wrong with that, right? Because that's
going to happen,
>> right?
>> But you will be successful, more
successful than you could ever be
>> with a coach
>> than if you don't have one. Yeah.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> You bet.
>> Back over to Ruth Ellen.
>> All right. Thank you, Mary. Thank you,
Mary. That was awesome. Thank you.
So, um, when you were talking
And um
I remember the first time that
somebody suggested I tell myself I love
myself.
>> Yeah.
>> And
>> was it hard? It was really hard because
like
>> I'm in a 12step program and you know I
used to be a different kind of person,
you know, and um and I had to forgive
myself for letting myself down and I
couldn't even like look myself in the
eye,
>> right,
>> in the mirror. I couldn't look myself in
the eye. Look at my eyebrow, my
eyelashes, my eye shadow, like whatever
I was doing. But for a long time,
>> yeah,
>> I couldn't even do that. I baldled like
a baby. I could I I
>> you know I'm crying
>> and and um
>> it was really hard.
>> Yeah.
>> In the beginning, but I pushed through
and I kept doing it and I do it and then
I started saying my full name like my
maiden name, my ex-husband, like all the
names I've had, even the the like secret
identity I had when I was running around
and not being a good girl. I was just
like I said all the names even even the
nicknames that my family gave him
because my grandpa used to call me
cricket because he as soon as he'd walk
in the room I'd sit down and be quiet.
As soon as he left I'd be all over the
place, noisy all over the place. He'd
walk in the room I'd sit down and be
quiet. And uh it it took me a while but
I finally got there. And and this this
is my mantra.
I can do anything.
>> Anything for 10 minutes.
>> Yes.
>> Sometimes it's hard and it's one minute
or 30 seconds. But this is this I have
two of these on my desk. I have one over
there and one over here. I can see it at
all times because you know um
like you said when you're building
confidence and you're on your own
because there's been a lot of time I've
been on my own and doing what I do and
uh fortunately my life isn't like that
anymore but um it's really important to
have certain things that you say and I
also say I can do all things through
Christ who strengthens
Yeah.
>> And um there's a few other sayings that
I have that I are my mantra, but my my
biggest one with my biggest fear
is I can do anything for 10 minutes. And
if today is just the most horrid day or
I'm going through something that's just
monumentally
hard, tomorrow will be a better day. I
can get through today.
Tomorrow is going to be a better day.
And I just focus on those things, you
know, and you know, I look at to you as
a coach and Paul a coach, but Cheryl,
you you and I used to work together
privately and
>> that made such a huge difference in my
life and it's like seriously I just
thank you so much for all of that and
you know and then I have all these
wonderful people that I work with and
Becca and um you know we all support
each other and then there are people
that we've been meeting along the way
and I'll be the first person like if you
need something call me let me know send
me a message and I'll do the best I can
um to get back to you quickly and I
learned all that from you
>> oh thank you
>> you and I did I because that's what you
said and you accepted me with open arms
you didn't even know me very well when I
came over for the Thanksgiving oh no
Christmas I'm sorry
>> and Um, you know, there there's another
thing I cuz sometimes I'm wrong, but I'm
okay being wrong. I can accept that I
was wrong and I'll say I was wrong
15 years ago.
Wouldn't have said that. Uhuh. Wouldn't
have said that. I'm a total, you know,
it's like amazing how much you grow with
age or whatever. But
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. So anyway, that's all I got to say
about what you said. It was
>> I love that though. I I think that's so
important. I think it's I think it's
great and I really want everybody to see
the change that it makes in your life
when you start and it it it's going to I
think it'll be hard for everybody, but
maybe there's some people that it won't
be hard for, but just to be able to say
that you love yourself, I think it
changes.
First of all, I think it changes the
energy that you put out into the
universe, which I think is
super important,
>> super important. And I don't think it's
super important so that you can get
something. I just think it's super
important because the better the energy
is that you put out, then the better the
energy is, I believe, that comes back to
you. And that's we all I mean, the
difference is just incredible, right?
And I've seen it. Believe me, I've seen
the different ways. So, if you can tell
yourself, you know, that you love
yourself and really
and continue to do it just like you
said. You said, "It wasn't easy and I
had to keep doing it." And you do have
to keep doing it,
>> right?
>> You do have to keep doing it. And think
of some things, too, and write them
down. Like, what are you good at?
Everybody is good at something. and
you're good at it and if you have to
call your friend and ask them then maybe
that's what you need to do or your coach
right because I think coaches have an
inside look at your life so if you have
a coach that you're working with you can
ask them hey what are some of the things
I'm good at like what from your
perspective right and I love that
because like my friends I know exactly
what they're good at and I can tell them
and I could give them a good long list
of things they're good at. So, and I
think that's the same way with with all
of us, you know, um when we have a great
friend or somebody that we hang out with
a lot, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, super important and and I think it's
also important I'm I just wanted to
touch on this real quick. I know we're
running out of time. I could and I guess
Mary's right. I could talk about this
stuff forever.
Um but um just I wanted to talk for a
second about that new um elevate your
health community because I think that is
so important. Um, I've wanted a
community for so long and and the reason
why is because I believe I saw this
documentary or read about it or
something about why people join gangs
because it's just that was so
fascinating to me
>> like why would somebody join a gang,
right? Like the anyway, but why? and
it's because they don't feel like
they're a part of something and they
feel like they don't have any connection
to anything. And so I was like, gosh,
that's so fascinating. So I've always
wanted to have a community of
like-minded people, right? A community
where we can give each other hope. We
can build each other up. We can see I
believe testimonials and stories are
what people learn from. I believe it's
how they how they um decide
um if they're going to buy something or
work with somebody. All of those things
are super important. So, I love that in
the community we have all of those
things. And I think most importantly the
the connection and the and a place for
people to be themselves and a place
where people can learn and gain this
knowledge um to help other people. So
that's the yeah the elevate your health
community I think is is a great place
for people to start and Ruth Ellen they
just have to talk to their health coach
or somebody to get the link to hop in
there right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Good.
>> Yes they do.
>> Yeah. And if you guys don't have a
health coach then let us know because
we'll find one for you. I know Ruthll
and you guys are good at that and and
helping people with that. Yes, we do
like to help people with that. That and
um getting people connected is very
important, you know, for all the reasons
that we've talked about today.
>> Yeah.
>> Come be the health coach gang because
that's a good gang to join.
>> You know, um yes,
>> it is. And it looks like uh Marilyn has
a question.
>> Yes, Marilyn. Would you like to unmute?
Hi.
>> Hi there, Cheryl. Yes, you are
wonderful. You're amazing. Revel's
amazing. This whole team is amazing.
>> You guys have made me grow. All of you.
I mean, even if sometimes I'm not
available and a replay, the replays even
help me. But as a kid, I I did so many
things, plays and performed and all
kinds of stuff. And I would shake so
uncontrollably,
and I didn't know why. And one time, one
day, I was talking to my husband and I
don't get why I shake cuz I'm so why do
when you're nervous, why do you shake so
much? And he says,
because he would always get up there and
be so confident whenever he performed.
And he says, Marilyn, you're focusing on
yourself and not the task at hand.
>> And that changed everything.
>> Instead of me thinking, oh, a is my hair
out of place or, oh my gosh, am I going
to fail? I I I can't I can't remember my
lines.
>> Instead, I just focus like on what I
need to do. And that I'm telling you,
that really helps.
>> Yeah. I love that. And focusing on the
audience,
>> focusing on what you're doing for them
and how they're feeling. That's
fantastic.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Oh, that's great. Okay.
>> But thank you all because I I'm telling
you, I had no at all.
So, you're amazing.
>> Thank you.
She's absolutely amazing.
>> Yes. And that is a great
>> There you go.
>> I love that.
>> Thank you, Carolyn.
>> All right.
So, do you have It's um the top of the
hour. Do you have anything other thing
that you want to wrap up with or
>> Yeah, I would just say I want everyone
to to tell themselves that they love
themselves because it's hard and it's
but I think that that's made one of the
biggest difference in my life that and
then having mantras to um because you
have to change the way that you talk to
yourself or you will stay where you're
at in and It could be and it could come
out as depression, right? That could
come out as depression because my
goodness, if you've got someone talking
to you
um with bad thoughts and bad things to
say all the time, of course you're going
to be depressed. Of course you are
because nobody wants to hear all of
that. And when you're doing it to
yourself, I think we're sometimes we
don't even know we're doing it
>> because we've been doing it for so long
>> because it's been it it's it is like
ingrained in us and
you know, we heard it from from our
parents or from kids at school or
wherever it was, right? And so we've
just picked up on that and it's a
pattern and Paul talks a lot about
patterns and I really do believe that
that you've just got to break that
pattern and by by realizing right
becoming aware
>> and then by doing those few things that
we talked about um you know gaining that
confidence and also learning how to love
yourself. I think that will make the
biggest difference in people's lives.
>> Yeah, I agree with you 100%. And I know
um Mark Jay always um says you know they
they have a master key system and um one
of the things they wrote a letter and
you're supposed to read it to the man or
woman in the mirror and that's that's
where
>> oh yeah
>> it it started for me and I I mean it
took me a couple days to get the words I
or you know out and and read um is
really important and Another thing that
has helped me um just because of you
know my history is
I am not my past.
>> Yep.
>> I am my present and my future. Now if I
was still living the way I did in the
past then that would be my present and
future. But that's not who I am anymore.
That's not what I want to do, you know.
And um
my sponsor
has told me that I am not a pest and my
past sponsors that I've had, you know,
that's not who you are anymore, you
know, and um
one of one of um my sponsors who that I
had in when I first got sober um he
passed away several years ago and Um,
like he was like,
"Ruth, don't talk to yourself like that.
Why are you saying that? That's not who
you are. You're magnificent. You're
growing. You're changing. You're not
stupid." Like, he gave me a hard time.
It was the last time I had a male
sponsor. And he was really my best
friend. And he talked to me every day
for 14 years. And when he passed away,
it was devastating. But that was one of
the things he said, "You are not your
past.
Don't ever think that you are your past.
>> Yeah, I love that. And I think it goes
right along with no matter where you
are,
>> no matter what you've done, you can
change. You can decide. And it's only
it's only up to you. Nobody else can
make you. No. Which I love that. No
one's going to make me. No one's going
to tell me to do anything, right?
Because I've always been like that. But
each of us can make that decision to to
change
our life completely around to change who
we are. If we don't like who we are and
if we don't like who we see in the
mirror, we can change that. And it only
has to do with us, right? That's the
only person that can do that. Which
again, I look at that as 1,000%
freeing. It frees you up to do what you
need to do, right? For yourself,
>> right? Yes.
>> Yep. This has been so much fun.
>> It has. It's been amazing. I've had a
really good time. Me, too.
>> And I was so excited before I was to see
you before you came up. So, thank you so
much for joining us today. I loved every
second of it.
>> Yes. Um and then um so you talked about
the coaches community. So if you want to
become a certified holistic health coach
and find out more about it, you can go
to co uh coach sorry
coach.dailywithdoc.com
and there's information there for you
and you could do that. And um if you
would like to talk to a certified
holistic health coach, you can call us
at 855-9493377.
And if you're working with somebody
directly, then call them because they'll
be your main point of contact. Um and if
I can get the co-host to come and join
me up here and sh me and Cheryl up here,
that would be great. And if you have
questions, um, you can send an email to
questionsailywithoc.com
and somebody will get back to you. And
if you have a question for Cheryl, do
they have a way of contacting you,
Cheryl, or we can have them put Cheryl
in their um,
>> subject?
>> Absolutely. And well, I was just going
to say if you're in the health
community, that's like a fantastic place
because that's where I'll spend most of
my time now that I'm back. So that's
probably the best place. But Ruth Ellen,
they can just also ask you and then you
can just text me or whatever and I can
to them. That's no problem at all.
>> That works.
>> Thank you so much, Ken. Cheryl.
>> Absolutely. It's a pleasure. I loved
seeing all of you and talking with you
today.
>> Yes. And Rebecca and I might be coming
your way soon.
>> Yes.
>> Everyone is welcome. You guys, we're so
excited about this. It is going to be an
incred It's for Jul it's going to be on
July 3rd
>> and it's like a Yeah, it's like for the
um country's 250th birthday. So yeah, if
you want to come then reach out.
>> We would love to see you.
>> Yes, I can't wait.
>> It's going to be so fun.
All right. So, helping us today is um
I'm going in order of my screen is Mary
who is out there on the different
platforms bringing in questions and
posting things and she is an and just an
amazing person as you saw when she was
talking to uh Cheryl. We love her. She's
one of our newest um supports for Daily
with Docs. Thank you so much, Mary. And
then we have Sherry who is part of our
tech crew and she helps me get all the
live stream stuff out. What I send to
her, then she sends it out and um
she's an amazing woman as well. And then
of course we have Miss Speedy Fingers,
Marilyn, who is also amazing and uh
we're just really grateful for all that
she does and her dedication. So thank
you. Thank you, Marilyn. And then we
have Albert who is our South African
health coach who answers the phone in
the middle of the night when we're
sleeping and he is our gatekeeper.
>> I love it.
>> And he is also I never give you credit
for this and I think you should get it.
A lot of the descriptions that get
posted with the shows he create he
writes after he's listened to the show
and taken notes and he does all these
other things. So, thank you so much
Albert. And then we have AJ who does not
have his camera on but he's our digital
marketing director and
there's so many things that he does I
can't even say. And of course Rebecca
Dukes, we love you. And then I'm Ruth
Ellen Sanchez. I am the executive
production manager for Daily with Doc
and Becca. And I just want to remind
everybody, please be kind. You don't
know what somebody's going through. And
like we said, they can have that mask up
that says everything is fine and it's
just not. So be kind. Say hello. Say
have a great day.
>> Yes.
>> Things like that. And um also
this program is for educational purposes
only and it's not meant to treat,
diagnose, cure anything. So thank you
Cheryl and thank you everybody. I am so
grateful that you are all here and um we
will see you tomorrow with pharmacist
Ben Fuges. Bye for now.
>> Bye. Thank you.
>> Thank you everybody.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
No.